We have talked quite a bit about how an image
is represented as a matrix inside a MATLAB.
Conversely, a matrix that we create using
MATLAB tools can be displayed as an image.
So what we are going to do now is use some
of MATLAB’s fundamental image creation tools
to produce some test images. So we are going
to create a new image purely through code.
So let’s start off by assigning to a workspace
variable im, my standard name for an image.
I am going to use the function zeros. And
what that does is create a matrix with dimensions
200 by 200 and all the elements in that matrix
are zeroes. And I am going to set one element
of that to the value of 1. Now I can display
this matrix that I just created as an image
and what we can see is this largely black,
because all the pixels are zero, which represents
black and up in the top left-most corner you
can see a tiny little patch of white. That
is the one pixel that I set to the value of
1—1 representing white.
Now, I can create a slightly bigger object
in this and what I am going to do is, within
this matrix, I am going to set all the pixels
from row 150 to row 160, and all the columns
from column 60 to column 70, and I am going
to set those to a value of 0.5. So that is
a grey, half way between black and white.
And I am going to set all those elements of
the matrix to the value of 0.5, now I can
display that matrix again and we see we have
created a small grey square in the image.
So we are creating an image simply by writing
code. The toolbox contains a function to create
circles. I am going to do that, I am going
to call the circle function, it is called
kcircle. And I am going to say I want a circle
of radius 30—we see that it has created
a matrix of dimensions 61 by 61. Let’s have
a look at this thing that we just created.
We can see here is the image representation
of that matrix. We can explore it using idisp,
and we see that all these pixels in here,
these matrix elements, have got a value of
1. And all these ones which don’t lie in
the circle have got a value of 0.
So this function has returned a matrix which
is square and the elements in that are either
0 if they don’t belong inside the circle
and white if they do belong inside the circle.
Now what we can do now is actually paste this
circle into the image that we had before,
so let’s just go back to the image that
we had a moment ago.
And I am going to paste the circle into that
image and I do it like this. I am going to
make the circle, not bright white, I am going
to make it a slightly brighter grey then the
square was. So I am going to multiply all
of the elements in the circle by the value
of 0.7, so it will have a 70% grey value.
And I am going to place the circle with its
centre at 100 by 30. So that is the u coordinate
of a 100 and the
v coordinate of 30.
All I have done now is updated the elements
in the matrix im. The value that I had before
and now it has got a circle pasted into it.
So let’s have a look at that.
And we see that the image now contains a square
and a circle. Toolbox has got some other functions
for creating graphical entities within a matrix.
Another function is iline and that draws a
line into a matrix. So I am going to draw
a line into the matix im.
The line is going to start at coordinate 30
by 40. And it is going to go to 150 by 190,
and I’m going to make it have a value of
90% grey.
Let’s display that. And there we have a
matrix which now contains a square, a line,
a circle and a single bright pixel.
Toolbox has got some functions to create slightly
more elaborate test patterns, accessed through
the test pattern function. And here I am going
to create a ramp function and I am going to
create an image of dimensions 200 by 200 pixels.
And let’s have a look at that.
And here we have what is called a grey scale
ramp. Let’s have a look at the grey scale
values in here. They are quite low, about
0.5 and as we move horizontally it gets brighter
and brighter all the way up
to 1. So if it is a grey scale ramp pattern
we can create more elaborate test patterns
such as grid of squares or circles.
Here is an example. We assign it to an output
variable im, use the test pattern function.
Ask for squares. We want the output image
to be 200 pixels by 200 pixels. We want the
squares to be on a 50 pixel spacing and we
want the squares to be 25 pixels square. Let’s display that image. And there we have a grid of 16 squares.